WINSTON CHANG: So this is in,
again, in the examples page.
And if we scroll down,
there's a section
that demonstrates
different types of outputs.
And so one of the
outputs is plot output.
And this is a really
basic example, once again.
So our UI is very similar.
We have an input slider.
And this time, we
have an output plot.
And it's named plot.
But just for clarity,
I'll call it myplot
just so that's not confusing.
Now for this example,
we also needed
to import matplotlib and numpy
to generate some random data.
So the code is pretty similar
to what we had before.
We have this output decorator.
And we have a render plot
decorator, this time,
instead of render text.
And it has some alt
text which will display
if you hover over the plot.
And then we have
the function that
actually generates the plot.
Now, these first
two lines here, this
is just some numpy code to
generate random numbers.
And then this is a
matplotlib histogram.
So we just say plt.hist.
We give it the data
that we generated.
And for this
particular function,
the second parameter is how
many bins are in the histogram.
So that's basically like how
wide each of these bars is.
So if I make it five,
there's five of these bars.
If I make it 100,
there's 100 of them.
And that's all that
it really takes
to create a plot in Shiny.
You just say render.plot.
And then if you're
using matplotlib,
you can say plt.hist.
And Shiny also currently
supports seaborn and plotnine.
And it also supports
other plotting libraries
that work in the browser.
So for example, it
supports plotly and Altair.
And those are supported via
the Shiny widgets package,
but I'm not going to go
over those right now.
But just so you
know, to use those,
you don't use render plot.
There's a different
function for those.
We'll have examples
for that as well.
So if we want to plot like an
actual data set instead of just
this fake histogram,
there's a great example data
set in a package
called palmerpenguins.
And let's import that like
this from palmerpenguins import
load_penguins.
Now, well, one cool thing
that you can do with Shiny
live is that I can actually
execute this line of code.
So I'm on a Mac.
So I can hit command enter and
it'll execute in the terminal.
On a Windows machine or Linux,
you'd press Control Enter,
but I'll just run it like that.
So this palmerpenguins
package it's just available.
And if I run
load_penguins down here,
it'll run it in this Python
console and print it out here.
So we can see that
this is a dataframe.
It's got 344 rows and 8 columns.
And it's got data about
various penguin specimens
that were in the wild.
So let's say we want
to take this data set
and make a scatterplot of
some of the measurements
that we took of these penguins.
So let's get rid of all
this, all this stuff here.
We're going to do
this differently.
And in fact, this
time we're also
going to use the seaborne
package for plotting.
So let's say import
seaborn as sns.
And then I also think
we don't need numpy.
We don't need matplotlib.
All right, so this
time, we're going
to do a different plot here.
So let's say we'll do
penguins equals load_penguins.
And now we want to make
a plot out of this.
So I actually happen to
have done this already.
This is like the
cooking show where
you put the pan in one
oven and you take it out
of the other one.
So this is the code
here for this plot.
And let's add a couple
of other things.
So in this case, I've created--
I've used seaborn to
create this plot object.
And then I'm going to
return that plot object.
Previously with matplotlib,
what I did was I just had it do
the plotting command instead of
returning a matplotlib figure
object.
And that's another way
that you can do it.
But in this case, I'm going to
have it return the plot object.
So if I run this, it's going to
take a moment to load seaborn,
I think.
And there we have
our scatterplot.
And this is a scatterplot for
the three different species
of penguins.
So that's what's happening
here, hue is species.
And we've also fit
these linear model lines
or these-- yeah,
linear model fit lines
to each subset of the data.
Now the slider doesn't
actually do anything right now.
So I could take it out
or I could figure out
what I want to do with it.
So let's say we just want to
look at one species at a time
instead of looking at
all of them all at once.
So right now, we have
this slider input that
doesn't actually do anything.
So let's get rid of that.
And let's add something
that lets us select
particular species to look at.
So let's say ui dot input, we
can do, how about input select.
So it'll give us
a selection box.
So we can say this is which
species you want to look at.
And let's say which
species is your favorite.
And then we can give
it a list of choices.
So I'm just going
to the next line
and say, Adelie, I hope that's
how to pronounce it, Gentoo,
and Chinstrap.
And then we can
put a comma there.
And another cool thing
about this online editor
is you can just
click this button
and it'll reformat
the code, in theory.
There we go.
I would expect it to be wide--
the editor be wide.
So that gives us--
we'll rerun this application.
And then we can select a
particular species of penguin.
And now, again, this is
not hooked up to anything.
We've just added
the UI component.
So in order to make this
actually work, let's say--
let's take a subset
of this data.
So we can say penguins
equals penguins where--
we can do it this way,
penguin species equals input.
All right, so this
is going to take
a subset for just one species.
And let's rerun this out.
So this is just showing us
the data for Adelie penguins.
And if we change
it, it's showing us
the data for Gentoo
penguins and Chinstrap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]